did you know you can do this in Hogwarts
Legacy
or pull off a combo like this
glaciers
I loved Hogwarts legacies combat the
very first time I had a chance to try it
and one of the first things I said is
that it would be easy to understand but
difficult to master and as I've been
progressing through the game I keep
learning more and more about the Nuance
of the combat and just how deep this
system really is not to mention it's a
lot of fun so the first clip I shared is
using the glacier spell to freeze an
enemy and then move in close for an
instant takedown with petrificus totalus
which I used to think was only available
in stealth what's more this also works
with aresto momentum so again you can
cast the spell and then move in close
for the takedown what's really
interesting about this is it does not
seem like you can do this when there are
other enemies aware of your presence in
the area so if you try and pull this off
right in the middle of battle with other
enemies around it just won't work if
this is actually how the developers
intend for this mechanic to work then
that tells me it's mostly intended as an
extra layer to the stealth mechanic
rather than something that's supposed to
be used In the Heat of battle I'm still
not completely sure on whether or not
I'd want to see it actually enabled in
the middle of fights I mean sure it
would be ridiculously good fun but it
could be just a little bit too strong I
don't know let me know what you guys
think of the comments for now we'll have
to enjoy it from stealth or as maybe a
nice visual Flex to finish off your
fight with a group of enemies glaciers
though is really useful just across the
board shout out to Boomstick gaming
which is where I first saw someone
performing this insane combo right here
guys this absolutely shreds and ever
since I saw this I've been having a ton
of fun with it I've also mentioned
before the importance of the field guide
and the collections page game director
Alan 2 even called this out on
avalanche's recent live stream urging
players to really pay attention to this
field guide and the information that's
in there a lot of the fights you could
be struggling with may have Simple
Solutions if you just knew how to
approach the enemy now one additional
layer that I have since learned about
this is what the field guide doesn't
always tell you and how it actually
leaves at least a little bit of the
strategy up to you to figure out and I
love this I love that it doesn't just
give every single thing away take for
example the Doug bogs which you can
levitate them by the Tongue using
levioso at just the right moment that of
course is in the field guide what the
field guide doesn't tell you is that if
you cast defindo right after that it's
going to almost always be an instant oh
so satisfying KO
one way to take your combat prowess to a
whole new level is by specking your
character's Gear with traits that
complement your play style and the
Spells you prefer to use this is really
where you can create some truly
incredible builds guys I'm working on
one right now I'm calling it The Merlin
build which places a priority on getting
my ancient magic meter filled as quickly
as possible but then in addition to
filling it quickly I also want to deal
out just an incredible insane amount of
damage with the powerful ancient magic
finishers and there are traits to do
both of those things now some of the
gear you find in Hogwarts Legacy will
have a trait already applied and it's
important to know that just because you
have a piece of gear with the trait it
does not mean that you've fully unlocked
that to use on any piece of gear so if
you have one and you really like the
trait don't sell or get rid of that
piece of gear or even change the trait
until you confirm that you do in fact
have that trait unlocked and again you
can do that inside the field guide you
can see exactly which traits you have to
unlock the trait so you yourself can
apply it to different pieces of gear
there's a bit of good news bad news here
the good news is that we know exactly
which activities in the game unlock more
traits to start you can obtain a few
specific traits by completing combat
challenges in the field guide book it'll
tell you exactly which ones you're going
to unlock by doing this for the rest of
the traits and there are 75 total traits
in all you'll need to take out Bandit
camps and find the loot chest inside the
camp and this takes us to the bad news
which is that it seems to be completely
randomized on which trait you unlock
from each specific band at Camp so I
can't tell you exactly which one to go
to if there's a very specific trait that
you're after the traits themselves are
split into two broad categories with
roughly half focusing on defensive
characteristics such as making your
character take less damage from a
specific enemy as well as offensive
characteristics like dealing out more
damage with specific spells like
confringo there are also three different
tiers to the traits with the most
powerful only being compatible with
legendary gear which is of course the
highest tier of loot in the game now
once you do have these traits fully
unlocked you can apply them as many
times as you want you're going to do
this using the enchanted loom in the
room of requirement now I say you can do
it as many times as you want but you
will have to weave this trait every
single time into the gear that you want
to apply it to so if you take it off and
you want to put it back on you have to
weave it yet again and to do this make
sure you're taking care of those magical
creatures inside the vivariums because
you have to have a steady supply of
those ingredients to weave these traits
for our next tip we're going to talk
about the cursed status effect and by
this point it's absolutely no secret
that the unforgivable spells are not
only in Hogwarts Legacy but that they're
actually really powerful in battle they
all have this curse status effect which
is noted in game with the little green X
you see here on the enemy now for my
first playthrough I'm doing a good play
through not learning any of the
unforgivable spells however I was
pleasantly surprised to learn that
there's much more to the dark magic
talent tree than first meets the eye
when you're just starting out you won't
have access to the talent tree yet so
don't worry if you can't find it right
now it's hard to say exactly when you
unlock these because it depends on how
many side quests you're doing how much
exploring around the open world but it
does happen as part of the main missions
and I personally unlocked it around the
10 hour mark but just know that even if
you aren't planning to learn the
unforgivable spells and definitely if
you are learning them you need to look
very closely at all the options in this
talent tree because you can actually
apply this curse effect on spells other
than just the unforgivables so just by
seeing that dark arts card don't think
that it only applies to the
unforgivables go ahead click there look
through and see if you have any there
that you want to use you can get it on
Expelliarmus for pindo even Stupify so
every time you block an attack with
protego and fire back that stupefy spell
the enemy that you hit will now have the
cursed effect so this effect it's going
to cause enemies to take even more
damage as long as they're cursed now I
personally think unlocking a few of
these cursed Talent options is
absolutely worth it but for sure you
want to be very careful about how you
spend these Talent points because you
cannot unlock everything guys and they
are not refundable who knows if we'll
get a respect option in the future maybe
in an update or if there's ever DLC but
right now just know that you need to be
absolutely sure but before you spin
these Talent points exactly where you
want to go with them you'll gain an
additional Talent Point each time you
level up with 40 being the current max
level in the game so as for leveling up
guys there's so much to see and do in
Hogwarts Legacy it's not always clear
what gives you experience toward
leveling up and what doesn't but it's
actually pretty straightforward once you
know exactly what to look for it all
starts and ends with your field guide
and the challenges inside completing
these challenges guys is how you level
up in Hogwarts Legacy and these
challenges they're tied to all sorts of
things like different Collectibles like
the field guidebook pages but many of
them are also tied to combat of course
you can complete these combat challenges
anywhere you can do battle but one of
the best places where you can
essentially Farm out these challenges is
with the battle arenas there are two of
these available to all players in
addition to the dark arts battle arena
which is included in the deluxe version
of the game or available as part of an
additional add-on you can purchase the
first one is in the North Ford bog
battle arena which is located all the
way at the very top of the map just
slightly to the right here the second
one is located on the southern side of
the feldcroft region and then if you
have access to the dark arts Arena it's
located in the Forbidden Forest these
can actually be pretty tough personally
I enjoy the challenge but if you are
just wanting to purely grind out the
challenges for XP you can always turn
down the difficulty to the game's
easiest setting which is story mode now
one final note here is that although you
can keep farming these challenges for
more experience that is only true up to
a certain point and it all goes back to
that field guidebook and those
challenges there once you have completed
those combat challenges you're not going
to earn any more XP for doing the stuff
here in the Arenas you can keep doing
them as much as you want practice use
them all you want but once you complete
those challenges you'll no longer earn
experience points for continuing to
battle it out in the combat Arenas now
if you do have any fights where you take
a few hits and lose Health make sure you
aren't needlessly wasting wig and weld
potions at the end of the fight I don't
even want to think about how many
potions I have wasted So In the Heat of
battle it's not going to refill but if
you end a fight and your health is not
at Max simply wait a few seconds and
you'll see it refill automatically all
the way without ever needing to use any
of your potions in the heat of battle
though of course you'll want to make
sure you always have a good supply of
these potions on hand you can actually
carry up to 25 of these at a time and
while you can buy them from Pippin's
potions in hogsmead and even find them
about the world it's going to be much
more efficient to brew your own once
you've unlocked the room of requirement
they're quick to brew and only require
two ingredients Clump juice and
dittany leaves the former which is quite
plentiful throughout the open world but
you can also purchase at Pippin's
potions in hogsmead the leaves can be
bought from various shops as well but
you'll want to make sure you buy the
seeds as soon as you can and then start
growing your own in the room of
requirement our next tip involves the
demigay statues that you're going to
find both inside various rooms at
Hogwarts as well as in buildings across
the Scottish highlands now personally I
think this sets off one of the most
important quests in the game because you
have to do this Quest if you want access
to everything if you want to be able to
get anywhere listen up regarding these
demigay statues because the first time
you come across them you may not be
completely sure what you're supposed to
do with him when you first see them
don't even waste your time don't try
spells it's actually not a spell that
you need to interact with these little
guys instead you have to first activate
a quest involving the Hogwarts caretaker
Gladwin moon now Moon actually has a
rather humorous story to go along with
the quest which I won't spoil it here
but I do love how different he is from
Argus filch the caretaker we're all too
familiar with from the original Potter
series to get access to this quest
You'll need to progress the main story
through the first trial the season will
then turn to fall and you'll get this
quest to pop from Mr Moon he'll also
teach you alohomora which is going to be
required for finding all of these
demigay statues there are actually three
levels to alohomora and you'll learn all
three of them from Gladwin Moon and
through this specific Quest once you've
kicked off the quest You'll then have an
understanding of what you're supposed to
do with these statues and as I mentioned
it does not involve using a spell you
simply collect them but you can only do
so when it's night time in the game
fortunately you can progress time
whenever you want by opening up the
game's map and then choosing the weight
option the map also includes a list of
all demigod statues as you hover over
various locations you'll be able to see
if there's a statue in the area and
whether or not you've obtained it okay
another really important note here on
the demigod statues guys you can use
revelio to help show you the location of
these however they will only light up
blue when it's evening so this can be
really tricky if you're in certain parts
of Hogwarts and aren't sure whether it's
night or day because you could just be
spamming revelio but they will not show
up even if you were right next to one as
long as it's daytime so you have to make
sure that it is night time if you want
to be using revelio to try and find
these guys and this actually ties in
perfectly with our next tip about
revelia which by this point I'm sure
you're already very well aware of just
how important the spell is it can reveal
so many different things visually even
through walls and through floors but in
addition to the visuals you'll also want
to make sure you're paying close
attention to the sounds with revelio
that's right if you have a good pair of
stereo headphones it is going to help
you pinpoint these Field Guide Pages if
you're running around Hogwarts or even
around the Scottish Highlands and you
hear this little chime that is an
indication that there is a field guide
page nearby
and the visuals they're certainly
important too here's an example of when
it helped me find a completely hidden
area that I had no idea was here
okay wait a second
revelio
that looks like we should be able to get
in
what this was not part of a quest that
just stumbled upon this randomly and
found an interesting note and a bit of
loot inside this door I'll see if you
can find it for yourselves next on our
list we have a few important notes here
about the Merlin trials puzzles which
are actually some of my favorite side
quests do in the game they're also the
key to unlocking more gear slots so
you'll definitely want to tackle as many
of these as you can to keep opening up
more slots I think they're pretty well
balanced in terms of providing just the
right amount of challenge without being
too insanely difficult now if you do
come across one that you feel is
insanely difficult it's quite possible
you just don't have the spell you need
to complete it that's right some of the
trials do require very specific spells
that you may not have access to yet it
could be even be spells that you could
learn you've just been putting them off
and the game will not tell you this so
you could be struggling for minutes
hours I don't know with one of these
trying to find the solution when in
reality all you need is a different
spell to help you move forward so I
would recommend learning each of the
spells in the game as soon as you have
the opportunity because it's just going
to open up the game so much more in
terms of everything you can do and
unlock just like with the moons and the
alohomora spell I should also point out
here that not all of the Merlin trials
even require a spell at all you'll see
similar trials because not all of them
are completely unique but there is quite
a variety and I don't want to completely
give away the solution here on how to
solve all of these but just know there
are times you'll need to think outside
the box a bit beyond just the Spells you
have and maybe you can even jump to a
few different conclusions from there one
of the other puzzles in the game is set
within Hogwarts and it's these arithmacy
doors there's actually a really simple
way to do this without needing any sort
of guide or cheat sheet you see each
magical creature depicted represents a
number and they're in order all around
the door you just have to remember it
starts from zero and not from one the
creature depicted at the very beginning
is a demi guys creatures in the
Wizarding World that can turn invisible
so just remember dimmy guys invisible
zero and start counting from there as
for the actual numbers as a simple
equation where you need the numbers and
symbols to add up to the one in the
middle and if you're having trouble
knowing which panel to activate because
there's is always going to be two panels
all you need to do is look at the
direction of the triangle and whether
it's pointing up or down then look at
the panel with the triangle pointing in
the same direction and that's the one
you need to set set it to the
appropriate creature based on the
numbers and you'll knock these out in no
time and really quickly guys I just want
to say thank you so much for all the
support lately it's been absolutely
amazing and if you're finding this video
helpful consider subscribing to the
channel for more it really helps me out
and I very much appreciate it alright
the last one here may surprise you
because while the arithmetic doors are a
great way to get some easy loot right
there within Hogwarts as you start to
travel outside the castle you're going
to encounter more and more of these
little loot bags a lot of times these
are on the ground and easily accessible
but other times they'll be in a more
hard to reach spot well I'm happy to
tell you that these loot bags you can
simply use the accio spell to pull them
toward you you will not be able to use
R3 though so you may need to use the
left trigger to zoom in a little bit and
line it up just right it also does not
work on the actual loot chests in the
game but these bags use accio every time
hey even if they're on the ground you
can still use accio you want now if you
really enjoyed these tips and tricks I
have another Hogwarts Legacy video here
I think you'll really enjoy and one that
would help you through your journey in
The Wizarding World as always witches
Wizards thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon